ferrat bonjour alors quels sont les
nouveaux éléments dans cette affaire
bonjour pierre en fait à ces ingérences
dans les affaires intérieures c'est
comme ça que la porte parole de la
diplomatie russe mais les acras a
qualifié l'appel de la france et de
l'allemagne libérée l'historien et
hulene me trifi
ce dernier vient d'être condamné à une
peine de prison de 13 ans pour violences
sexuelles sur sa fille adoptive pour mai
à rabat ça n'a rien à voir avec ses
activités politiques
écoutez quant à la condamnation du
citoyen russe youri dmitriev par la cour
suprême de carélie je rappelle que sa
peine pour violences sexuelles sur sa
fille adoptive mineur a été alourdie
nous considérons la démarche de
l'allemagne et la france comme un acte
d'ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures de la fédération de russie
et une tentative de remettre en question
une décision prise par des tribunaux
indépendants de la fédération de russie
ces activités précédentes n'ont rien à
voir avec cela personne ne met en doute
ses états de service dans les recherches
sur les répressions politiques en urss
sa condamnation est une question qui
relève exclusivement du droit pénal
si vous rassure je dis mais je discute
pour ce casting est ce que nos collègues
allemands et français n'en sont pas
informés ou bien ils ne veulent pas
l'être à cet égard nous estimons que les
appels lancés par berlin et paris visant
à libérer youri dmitriev condamné pour
pédophilie sont inacceptables du point
de vue moral et éthique
la france et l'allemagne réclament la
libération de nitrites et je cite à la
fin des attaques contre la société
civile en russie
la sphère de 2000 livres monte à près de
quatre ans celui qu'on qualifie de
chroniqueurs du goulag avait été arrêté
une première fois en 2016 et a été
accusé d'avoir réalisé des images
pornographiques de sa fille adoptive
l'historien expliqué qu'il avait besoin
des photos pour suivre son évolution de
santé selon ses défenseurs est lui-même
à l'instigation étaient liées à ces
recherches sur des disparus sur les
purges staliniennes acquitté deux ans
plus tard il revient encore une fois sur
le banc des accusés à la suite d'une
lettre provenant de sa fille adoptive où
il détaille son calvaire
ils sont évoquées notamment des
violences verbales et physiques y
compris sexuels ainsi que des séances de
photos hebdomadaire à laver de lundi du
verdict plusieurs photos d'elle qui
figure dans l' enquête ont fuité dans la
presse provoquant l'indignation sur les
réseaux sociaux russes viol et demie
tiff assure à son tour de vouloir encore
se battre pour sa libération
merci beaucoup à vera wang
donc en direct de moscou